wait spider-man's the son of the tiger
from Life of Pi
I'm Richard Parker's son Peter Parker
you do have secrets Life of Pi so Life
of Pi is directed by angleene it's the
story of a kid named Pi actually his
name is pissing he shortened it to PI
for obvious reasons and the story
unfolds in a way where he's older now
he's telling his life story to a guy
he's telling the story of when his
family was moving from India to Canada
and this big ship sinks and there were a
lot of animals on the ship because they
owned a zoo hai ends up in a lifeboat so
now it's just pi and a tiger named
Richard Parker and now this is our story
our story is the time in which this kid
Pi was stuck in this lifeboat with this
tiger that could be really awesome
or it could be boring as hell luckily
it's not that second one Life of Pi is
really interesting and I heard that Life
of Pi is just an unfilmable book you
can't translate the book to a movie but
how often have we heard that we're
coming up on 2013 now there's really
nothing we can't do on the big screen
now granted how its executed will either
make it feel like a big CGI [ __ ] fest or
you use the special effects in
technology to help tell the story in
which case it actually enhances it or at
least makes it fillable That's Life of
Pi visually Life of Pi is really
impressive it's one of those movies
where it's like oh yeah it's 3d but well
played the 3d was actually really cool
and the visuals were just out of this
world like the scene when that ship is
sinking and it shows PI under the water
and he's looking at this humungous
tanker just sink was almost haunting
it's like something nightmares are made
from it was done really well it was just
like one of those visual things where I
was like yeah I wanted to see that in a
movie I wanted to see a tanker sink but
see it under water Life of Pi gave me
that now the meat of this story is the
relationship between PI and Richard
Parker this Tiger giving the tiger a
name makes him more of a character than
he should have been you could have just
had a tiger and pie but unless they
really pulled a big trick out of a hat
it probably would have felt like a tiger
and our character naming him Richard
Parker gives it a boost to make him an
actual character then establishing and
carrying on a relationship between
Richard Parker and PI just yeah the
Tigers a character never talks it's not
corny or anything like that it's all he
has a voice he's an animal which makes
it more impressive now when I say
relationship I don't mean
yeah their friends are not really
friends they're more or less nemesis to
senses nemesis is that's how you say all
right they are each other's nemesis
there you go and the whole while they're
playing this territory game on this
lifeboat is a relationship of conflict
and necessity which let's face it is a
hundred times more interesting than any
relationship of love I see a
relationship like this like making a
sword you beat the [ __ ] out of it you
heat it you cool it you smash it you
bend it but in the end you have this
awesome tempered steel sword that's
stronger because it went through that
that's a relationship of conflict and
that is Life of Pi or at least one of
the elements in Life of Pi and on this
you have a coming-of-age story it's kind
of like if I had to describe Life of Pi
it would be castaway he's a kid in a
lifeboat with a tiger there's really not
much like it out there but I enjoyed
seeing the conflict between PI and this
tiger I enjoyed the territory war that
they had with each other I enjoyed
seeing how one needed the other to
really survive but they never made it
cheesy you know they never made it like
oh hey me and the tiger were pals
to Life of Pi is a really well done
coming-of-age story visually it's
impressive his house it's one of those
movies that shows yes you can use the
technology of our time to make a really
interesting and visually appealing movie
without making it a CGI [ __ ] fest Life
of Pi for a rated PG movie is actually a
little darker than you think it's gonna
be and it's a bit thicker too I don't
know like you know a 10 year old that
will be interested in the entire movie
it's a movie that's made for teenagers
older teenagers and adults that happens
to be rated PG I will say Life of Pi is
worth buying on blu-ray
I saw your favorite coming-of-age story
Life of Pi being a coming-of-age story I
think it's an appropriate question
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more